in the opening scene we are introduced
to a family of two the mother grace and
her six-year-old daughter lisa they live
a happy happy life in the outskirts of
seoul being a single mother grace does
everything she can for her little girl
at first glance they look like a normal
happy family but we soon discover that
as time passes lisa is growing younger
grace knows this and is worried about
her daughter disappearing someday this
is why she tries spending as much time
with her as she can but eventually six
years pass and like she had predicted
lisa grows shorter every year and
eventually goes back into her mother's
belly i call this the curious case of
benjamin bellybutton she softly holds
her knowing she only has nine months
left and they won't meet again because
her life is moving backwards however
time didn't always move backwards for
grace it all started in august of 2019.
grace is living happily with her
daughter and time moves forward for them
just like it does for anyone else but
everything changes one day when lisa is
murdered at the hands of a mentally ill
man grace's entire world crashes as she
tries her best to keep herself together
moreover the murderer got away with the
act because of his mental condition
grace has been protesting his
imprisonment but it only causes her more
trouble the only reporter on her side
tells her to stop because the murderer
is somewhere in the hospital where all
his needs are being taken care of in
addition her boss warns her to stop the
protest because it gives their company a
bad reputation when grace loses all will
to live she finds a group of depressed
people trying to commit the unthinkable
they decide to meet on august 16th and
travel to the countryside where they
will take sleeping pills and commit the
unthinkable together before going to
meet them grace places her diary on her
daughter's grave with all their pictures
and notes on it since grace has only
talked to the group on the phone she is
a bit late to the location upon finally
reaching the place she meets park like
everyone else in the group he is also
tired of his life on their way to the
countryside everyone silently listens to
the radio announcing a meteor shower
happening in a few hours while the rest
of the world is excited to witness
something magical this group doesn't
care they finally reach a small cottage
just when the meteor show starts the
pills are distributed and eaten before
everyone goes to sleep one girl in
particular named suna has trouble
swallowing the pills so grace asks her
to crush them at midnight tsuna wakes up
and starts vomiting this is followed by
the rest of the group waking up in a
similar fashion in the following scene
we see park and tsuna on hospital beds
next to each other the doctors are
trying their best to save park but
eventually they announce his death grace
can hear them talking but is in too much
pain to react to the situation upon
glancing at park's dead body she sees
him wake up he tells her to wait until
he remembers her grace doesn't know what
that means but the words leave a print
on her mind the scene changes to the
next day grace wakes up and to her utter
surprise the date is still august 16th
she is supposed to meet the rest of the
group in a few hours even though she
remembers all of them dying last night
grace dismisses this as a dream and does
everything she did yesterday because she
knows where they are supposed to meet
she isn't late today like she was last
time the day goes as planned and at
night grace crushes the pills for soon
off without her asking this further
makes her believe that she wasn't
dreaming but grace is now ready to end
her sufferings and doesn't have time to
dwell on what happened last night they
take the pills and fall asleep the next
morning comes and the date goes back to
august 15th grace puts two and two
together to figure out that her life is
moving backward since august 17th she
immediately goes to her psychic sister
anna and tells her what happened anna
doesn't believe her and asks her to go
to the doctor this is when it hits grace
that even if her life continues going
backward no one will believe her because
she would not be able to meet them in
the future for the next few days every
time grace wakes up she goes back a day
into the past on some occasions she
decides to stay awake the entire night
but as soon as the clock hits 12th she
is miraculously transported to her bed
as the day moves forward she remembers
everything that is about to happen that
day and can even forecast the weather
the most useless superpower of them all
however grace doesn't mind living this
way because this will mean she will get
to meet her daughter and prevent her
death very soon as days pass grace grows
angrier at the person who killed her
daughter before the little girl returns
to life grace wants to kill the murderer
one night she goes to the hospital where
he is admitted and tries to suffocate
him to death she only stops when park
comes into the hospital room revealing
that the murderer is his mentally ill
father he doesn't remember grace because
he's not living in the past like she is
but he seems to recognize her face to
some extent grace is so shocked that she
runs away without saying a word a few
more days later comes the day of lisa's
funeral grace is not half as sad as she
was the last time knowing that she will
soon get a chance to save her daughter
she even refuses to put up a picture of
lisa on the grave it is then revealed
that when lisa died she was on a school
trip with her teacher and friends hence
when grace wakes up the following
morning the first thing she does is call
lisa's school teacher asking her to keep
an eye on the little girl for the next
few hours after that she rushes to seoul
to the resort where the students are
staying on her way grace also makes sure
to call the police and tell them about
an insane man trying to kill her
daughter somewhere else we see park
taking care of his mentally ill father
david park has been living with his
father for the past few years and is
tired of the old man ruining everything
going on in his life this morning when
david refuses to get into the house park
rudely throws him out hoping they will
never meet again at the same time lisa's
teacher falls asleep and the girl
wanders out to the swimming pool area
where she meets david they go to a small
farm by the resort and get some eggs
david says he is bringing them for his
son and is happy to have found the
little girl as a friend but while trying
to cross the pool the eggs fall into the
water david goes in to retrieve them but
behind him lisa falls into the deep end
and starts drowning david is trying his
best to save her when the police officer
and grace arrive at the same time grace
finds her daughter alive and is washed
with relief she wants david to be
arrested before lisa tells her that
david is her friend who saved her grace
finally realizes that she had been
protesting for the wrong thing because
david was never at fault for the death a
while later park comes to pick up his
father regretful for treating him the
way he did in the morning grace
recognizes him yet again and tries to
chat with him but he treats her like a
stranger before walking away with his
father the next morning grace wakes up
and breaks into tears upon seeing her
daughter sleeping by her side later lisa
asks her mother to stop crying by
writing it down in their shared diary
the one grace left on the grave earlier
it is then revealed that the diary has
traveled backward through time and has
everything grace wrote in the future in
it days become months as grace lives her
best life with her daughter even though
they age backward and she is worried
about lisa disappearing after a few
years she is happy to have spent more
time with her years pass and soon grace
returns to 2011 when she is nine months
pregnant with lisa after giving birth
she holds lisa for a few extra minutes
knowing that it is the last time she
will meet her in person just as she had
thought the next day she is back to
being pregnant which is difficult
because she will eventually lose the
baby altogether and go back to her
younger self with time grace makes peace
with the fact that she will never see
her daughter again then one afternoon
she finds a letter on the back of the
diary to her surprise it is a message
from park where he apologizes to her for
her daughter's death and blames himself
because he left his father alone that
day it turns out that he wrote this
letter a day before he decided to commit
the unthinkable he visited the grave on
the same day and put the letter inside
the diary grace left when park and grace
met on the 17th of august he was shocked
because he knew she was the mother of
the girl who died grace remembers park's
last words to her he asked her to wait
until he remembers her she realizes that
she needs to find him and make him
remember the future where they died
together this might also be the answer
to turning back time into its original
form after doing some research grace
finds the address of dwight the last
member of the group who wanted to commit
the unthinkable she meets him and
discovers that he has also been living
life backwards since the day they died
unlike grace dwight is having fun living
life this way because he is destined to
grow younger and die the traumatic part
of his life is over and now he just
wants to live until the inevitable comes
they remember sunnah and dwell about
what she might be doing in her life upon
looking for her for a while they find
her about to sign a deal with a company
that is bound to ruin her life they stop
her from signing the contract which
further saves her life in the future a
few months later grace is with her
sister when she happens to bump into
park he works as a delivery man for a
furniture company he obviously doesn't
recognize her but grace makes sure to
ask for his card to contact him later
the next day she goes to his work and
saves him from rude customers trying to
get him fired moreover it turns out to
be his first day at work after standing
up for him she follows him home and is
later confronted park assumes she is a
stalker before she tells him that she
knows him from the future that's
honestly a really good line for a
stalker he doesn't believe her but she
has decided to make him remember her at
all costs in the next scene we see grace
going to park's work again this time she
finds him interviewing for the job the
interviewer doesn't take park seriously
because of his shoulder injury after the
interview grace introduces herself to
park again she pretends to be someone
random and asks him out for drinks once
park is drunk grace shows him his card
asking him not to worry because he is
bound to be selected by the end of the
date grace finds out that park used to
be a skilled taekwondo fighter a few
weeks ago he had a very important match
where he suffered a shoulder injury it
ended his career and triggered his
father's mental illness grace watches
the videos of the said fight determined
to stop the worst from happening the day
of the fight comes and she tries her
best to stop park from going through
with it she even tells him about his
father's health and his shoulder and
even though park believes her to some
extent he is not willing to give up at
this point of his life he enters the
ring and gets his shoulder broken just
like he did the first time his father
david suffers a stroke as grace watches
her plan fail in misery in the following
scene grace meets dwight upon finding
out that her only wish is to see her
daughter he reveals that a meteor shower
is about to take place in a few months
according to dwight the time is moving
backward for them because they tried to
commit the unthinkable during the last
meteor shower hence if grace is willing
to risk her life again this might be her
chance to change her fate and turn the
time into its original form grace
immediately decides to go through with
the plan for the slightest chance to see
her daughter again a few weeks pass then
comes the day of the meteor shower grace
goes to meet park for the last time to
wish him farewell but instead she meets
david he is in a good condition which is
a strange sight for grace she apologizes
to him for misjudging him and runs to
look for park at his practice to her
misfortune park turns out to be partying
with his friends the same day she looks
for him for hours before giving up and
getting on a bus to the han river but by
a strange twist of fate park ends up on
the same bus as her glad to see him
there grace gives him the diary and hugs
him for the last time after she leaves
park opens it and finds the journals
about grace's experience by the time he
reads all of it he remembers every
encounter he has had with grace until
now upon finding out about her plan to
commit the unthinkable he runs to the
han river the scene cuts abruptly when
grace jumps into the water she wakes up
the next day but it turns out that the
plan worked and now time has started
moving forward for her again park also
continues living but he regularly reads
the diary grace gave him currently he is
getting ready for the same match that
could make or break his career but this
time he has park's diary in his hands
guiding him his fate changes because of
the diary making him win the game his
father doesn't get a stroke and the two
are happier than ever a year passes and
grace goes into labor again she gives
birth and finally gets to meet her
daughter with the knowledge she has of
the future she can protect the little
girl in the last scene park meets grace
and hands her the diary back in the end
both of them live a good life one with a
better career and the other with her
daughter
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching